[Music]
clearly she should not have reacted the
way she did however it is a normal human
reaction with both the somatic and the
autonomic nervous systems we have to
respond when under threat so she was
being a great responded that was
California radio talk show host Ethan
Biermann on his show LA on this show
last Friday defending the New York Times
hiring of Sara's young despite her
racist anti white anti-cop tweets
Biermann later uploaded video of that
segment to Instagram right a lot of
people do that but it was deleted an
Instagram spokesperson told us quote
this posters moved in error and we are
sorry it has been since reinstated
Ethan Biermann joins us right now Ethan
why do you think that happened you were
just retweeting something and actually
defending the Times writer to a degree
and that not only that Brian good to see
you tonight by the way is Tucker and I
didn't actually quote Sara Jung's tweets
we were having a conversation about it
the only thing I can come up with right
now is on social media we are so divided
people are so angry about things we're
unable to have conversations that
somebody whether it was on the left or
the right at this point was very angry
that we were even having the
conversation and people are Petty and
reached somebody said flagged it and
Instagram lacks the systems to actually
review what is being posted before they
remove it and so they removed it I found
it really upsetting I've actually omit
didn't make any sense when I saw it was
removed but you know you're not the
first one but you are as someone who's
not necessarily a conservative talk show
host for someone to take that down
because you were talking about a topic
that many conservatives found offensive
and I think Americans found offensive
and that was her prior tweets and
statements what does it tell you about
where we're heading well again I think
it's it's problematic that we can't have
a conversation or that people are upset
by even having the conversation look
there are definitely legitimate concerns
when people post hateful things some of
the messages I get about my Jewish
background are absolutely reprehensible
and should be taken down and should be
flagged and marked and
not if you're gonna viciously attack
somebody and or call for violence there
is no place for that and I agree with
these platforms preserving their terms
of service and protecting those edges
but just to have the conversation about
something Brian you and I engage in
debate regularly I think it's important
I think it's healthy and I think that we
all grow when we're engaged in healthy
debate calling names calling for
violence not necessarily a good thing
and especially calling for violence I
reserve the right of those platforms to
remove those posts 30 seconds left Ethan
do you think this is bots is this is
this a an algorithm what do you think
this is a human being doing this stuff
well I think overall the platform's have
to have algorithms for removing posts
and I think that where we've kind of
gone too far with this is they default
to removing first and then only when
like Fox News reached out did a human
bother reviewing to say yeah there's
nothing wrong with this post and and so
yeah we're counting on algorithms first
and I think they still have a lot of
work to do it's just amazing so many
times the topics that are conservative
or getting targeted but in this case you
talking about something got targeted
either will stay on top of that thanks
so much Brian good to see you thanks for
having me on